welcome back to Las Vegas now I know
we're cooking away we're excited you
guys and you know now that we have
professional sports teams in Las Vegas
we are learning the proper way to
tailgate or maybe we can just leave it
to the professionals at tailgate social
here with us with one of their new menu
items and let me tell you it smells
delicious we have Aida and Kita thank
you guys for being here thank you I love
tailgate social it's so much fun in
there the food is delicious before we
get to this aita I'll start with you and
just have you kind of tell us about the
the atmosphere when you come into
tailgate social I would tailgate social
it's a great sports bar and Beyond right
like we have like a great menu menu
addition so we're bringing this Lobster
boil for the summer just as a extra to a
great sports bar with a 30 plus TVs and
20 plus draft beers and now you know a
new menu item so um yeah tailgate is
great we have games shuffleboard pool uh
NBA Jam so yeah you guys have it all and
such an elevated dining experience I
always have always have fun when I'm in
there so let's get to it this is looking
good can you tell us a little bit about
what's going on in the pot here yes
today we have our main lobster excuse me
our New England Lobster boil we have the
whole main lobster it's going to also be
served with the sausages corn and or
potatoes with a side of our drawn butter
oh my God we also have some lemons as
well to top that off with oh and we're
getting a facial yeah
okay well it looks very pretty in there
but I would love to Plate it and show
everyone your Masterpiece all right so
we'll just go ahead I'm going to take
this out please be careful of course
look at this you guys see oh my God
fully loaded so and this you get all of
this you get all of this for 23 wow
that's an amazing deal I know it's on
right now all the way until August so
please come by and check it out with us
special fun display too okay we have
about 30 seconds here so I want to make
sure that we get everything out there
and we cannot forget about the butter
yes and while you're fixing up that
plate over there I'm gonna get ready I
hear that you have to have a bib that's
the proper way to to eat and knowing me
I'll spill everything I don't even know
how to do it the right way okay we'll
put the bib on here really quickly okay
and as we're getting ready as we're
wrapping up here just really quickly
tailgate social tell everyone where it
is when they can come see you guys and
if you recommend reservations yeah so uh
we're inside the Palace Station and uh
recommend
agents are not required but recommended
of course we are open every day four to
four to nine and also we have Sunday
brunch uh it starts at 11. so I'm all
about a brunch okay yeah bottomless in
the middle says oh you can't go wrong
with that all right we're wrapping up
here my bib may have fallen off a little
bit but I'm gonna dig in and tune into
our social media we'll do some other
stuff so you guys can see everything
Rocky I'll send it over to you thank you
Jillian you're struggling